Jimmy Kimmel shares an update on his
son's heart condition he's gonna have to
have another operation soon and but
everything's going great
[Music]
et caught up with the Jimmy Kimmel Live
host who will be taping his show in
Brooklyn this week the kids will be with
us my wife was the head writer on the
show we'll be going and we take
everybody and he opened up about his
five month old son Billy who underwent a
life-saving heart surgery in April due
to a congenital heart defect how's your
son doing how everything good with him
he's doing great he's he's a fat little
baby and he's he's getting big he's
gonna have to have another operation
soon and but everything's going great so
far it was a amazing night when you gave
that monologue and talked about your son
you touch so many people no parent
should ever have to this life it just
shouldn't happen people were so nice and
people still are so nice everybody you
know they come up to me to ask me how
Billy is and then you know and it's it's
really nice to see to get that from
people and I think it's the result of
energies being on television for many
years and you feel like you know
somebody and and it you know people say
they're praying it means a lot and do
you find that people now look to you as
much as the your monologues as much for
what you are saying because you've said
some things that you know people instead
of laughing they said well you know what
I agree with that guy and it's got it's
caught people's attention on Capitol
Hill we want quality affordable health
care it's about time somebody's agreeing
with me but of course there are many
people that disagree and that's the risk
of giving your opinion because typically
talk to a hose don't give their opinions
but times have changed drastically and
you know you want to talk about what's
happening in the news that day and
sometimes things touch you personally
and sometimes things really hit home
[Music]
you